dans notre émission spéciale consacrée à
l'examen de la forme de retraite
continue évidemment on va évaluer
maintenant la mobilisation des grévistes
à l'avant veille d'une nouvelle journée
de manifestation la France était la
première réponse Flora sauvage les
poubelles qui s'empilent dans les rues
de Paris au troisième jour de la grève
au conductible dans plusieurs secteurs
de l'économie le mouvement a été levé
dans la raffinerie de port Jérôme
Gravenchon en Normandie où les
expéditions de carburant ont repris par
tout ailleurs dans les raffineries la
grève a été reconduite mais il n'y a pas
de pénurie à la peau à ce stade sur 200
dépots de carburant 5 étaient bloqués
mercredi soir dans les transports le
trafic à la SNCF s'annonce fortement
perturbé ce week-end après la sixième
journée de mobilisation mardi les
syndicats réclament le retrait de la
réforme et une rencontre avec Emmanuel
Macron quand il y a des millions de
personnes qui sont dans la rue quel est
le rôle du président de la République de
de jeter de l'huile sur le feu ou de
calmer le jeu et de dire ouh là bon on
va regarder peut-être que je me suis
trompé du dévisser la mobilisation reste
limitée le ministère de l'Éducation a
comptabilisé 15 établissements bloqués
et cette partiellement ici un des
étudiant aux manifesté cet après-midi à
Paris à l'appel des organisations de
jeunesse le campus de Lille est bloqué
lui pour la deuxième journée consécutive
on est venu pour montrer que c'est une
lutte qui va être longue qui va devoir
durer que la grève que ce soit dans les
facs pour soutenir en fait le mouvement
de grève dans les entreprises elle va
devoir être conductible mais Elisabeth
borne oppose une fin de non-recevoir au
syndicat qui ont annoncé une nouvelle
journée de mobilisation samedi
dans le projet de réforme on continuera
à être à l'écoute à l'écoute aujourd'hui
des parlementaires puisque le débat est
désormais au Parlement face au
gouvernement qui reste droit dans ses
bottes certains opposants à la réforme
veulent durcir le mouvement ce matin
plusieurs centaines de militants de la
CGT énergie on privait d'électricité le
Stade de France et le chantier olympique
de Seine-Saint-Denis là vous avez on va
débattre autour euh de cette réforme des
retraites on continue de de cette idée
d'une France à l'arrêt pour pour
commencer de la mobilisation de mardi
évidemment avec Stéphanie Villers
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes conseiller
économique chez PwC France Maxime qui
joue bonsoir bienvenu spécialiste du
syndicalisme et du travail et chercheur
au CNRS anne-charles bézina bonsoir et
bienvenue vous êtes constitutionnaliste
et Bruno bonsoir bienvenue docteur en
économie et chercheurs associés à l'OFCE
mardi la plus forte mobilisation depuis
le début de ce mouvement plus de monde
que lors des cinq premières journées
entre 1 million 280 000 ça c'est le
chiffre des des préfectures du ministère
de l'Intérieur et puis 3 millions 500
000 selon l'Inter syndical qui ont donc
manifesté mardi Stéphanie Villers on
peut parler d'une mobilisation
historique le terme n'est pas galvaudé
sur quoi peut-être déboucher maintenant
si on essaye de se de se projeter un peu
sur le capital que représente une telle
mobilisation mais on voit bien que
même si la réforme passe et voter ça va
être compliqué de d'avoir l'adhésion de
l'opinion publique c'est à dire que les
deux ans supplémentaires et bien la rue
exprime son mécontentements et en fait
on voit tout la problématique de la
communication du gouvernement autour de
cette réforme parce qu'il y avait quand
même des arguments à donner des
arguments comptables mais aussi
objectif compte tenu de et bien de notre
démographie c'est qui je rappelle que le
système de répartition est basé sur
notre démographie c'est à dire notre
espérance de vie et notre taux de
fécondité donc il y avait de vrais
arguments Tangi mais pour autant en fait
défendable elle a été mal défendue c'est
ce que vous nous dit elle a été oui
absolument elle a été mal proposée parce
que derrière en fait une équation
comptable on n'a pas le gouvernement n'a
pas réfléchi
aux solutions à mettre en place
notamment pour les seniors en on y
reviendra évidemment on a une heure
devant nous donc il y a le temps de
développer de détailler beaucoup de
thèmes on reviendra sur le l'essence
même de cette réforme je suis pas sûr
que vous disiez qu'elle est défendable
donc je vous le donnerai l'occasion dans
dans débattre un peu plus tard mais je
reste sur cette première thématique de
on va essayer de se projeter dans la
foulée de cette mobilisation très forte
il y a différents scénario ou scénaris
Maxime qui joue dans les prochains jours
les soufflements fait partie c'est pas
le seul oui alors simplement pour
revenir quand même sur cette dimension
historiques je pense qu'elles sont
importantes c'est la mobilisation qui a
le plus réuni pour certains
commentateurs le plus de monde depuis
plusieurs décennies donc je pense que
c'est important le matin de l'unité
syndicale des cortège massifs et
toujours ancré dans les territoires je
pense que c'est quelque chose
d'important 280 villes
ça augmente tous les jours oui tout à
fait l'élargissement du mouvement
également il y a les éboueurs qui sont
rentrés dans la bataille les dockers
chose qu'on a moins entendu les
travailleurs de la sous-traitance qui se
sont mobilisés de massive presque autant
que le reste du salariat c'est quelque
chose qui est tout à fait nouveau et qui
était voulu les syndicats cherchent à
sortir de ces grèves par procuration et
visiblement ça commence à prendre forme
soutien populaire il y a un sondage qui
est sorti récemment dans l'humanité 65 %
des Français sont pour la grève
reconductibles et enfin moi ce qui m'a
beaucoup intéressé c'est quand même le
soutien médiatique on voit que la
plupart des éditorialistes s'accordent
sur trois points le succès de la
mobilisation le caractère trompeur
finalement de la retraite pour y revenir
effectivement et l'attitude
incompréhensible voire irresponsable du
chef de l'État moi j'étais très surpris
d'entendre des éditorialistes y compris
sur des chaînes qui a priori serait
plutôt en tout cas favorable à la
réforme à voir cette attitude là je sais
pas quels sont les chaînes favorables à
la réforme en tout cas forcément
identifié
des éditorialistes qui ne seraient pas a
priori forcément favorable à des
blocages à une France alors je repose ma
question sur la suite parce que sur
l'essoufflement je dis je sors pas ça
comme ça de mon chapeau c'est vrai que
par exemple la RATP annonce une net
amélioration du trafic demain sauf sur
une ligne qu'il y a une des raffineries
bloqué celles des scènes exon mobile qui
a été débloqué les expéditions carburant
qui reprennent je tire pas de plan sur
la comète mais voilà c'est l'un des
scénarios alors absolument effectivement
les soufflements c'est la l'hypothèse
kiwi qui vient à l'esprit de tout le
monde alors il y a pas eu trop de
répression pour l'instant mais si le
mouvement se durcit on peut supposer
qu'il y aura une répression qui va
pouvoir un peu décourager les gens et le
coût de la grève on en a beaucoup parlé
effectivement ça constitue un obstacle
important pour la continuité de la grève
certains dans certains secteurs ont déjà
été en grève l'année dernière donc il y
a beaucoup de secteurs qui ont déjà eu
un coup assez élevé d'un point de vue
économique et puis cette stratégie des
journées de moutons au bout d'un moment
on va peut-être voir un essoufflement
mais il y a une autre hypothèse
peut-être à laquelle on va revenir sur
la radicalisation absolue alors ça je
vous laisserai en parler tout à l'heure
si vous le voulez bien je devrais que
tout le monde puisse prendre la parole
une première fois unchaine businaia la
stratégie de l'interdy syndicale on le
voit depuis le début c'est vraiment un
passionnant c'est de de dater de choisir
les moments de journée d'action les plus
fortes les prochaines c'est 11 et 15
mars en fonction du calendrier
parlementaire
pour l'instant est-ce qu'on peut dire
que ça marche moi j'ai un doute mais bon
il y a quelque chose qui est certain
c'est qu'en tout cas le mot d'ordre
c'est la popularité ce que ne veut pas
perdre l'Inter syndicale c'est cette
idée d'avoir un soutien de la base
d'avoir un soutien même bien plus large
que la base syndicale et de rendre plus
facile par exemple le fait de manifester
pour les jeunes mamans de rendre plus
facile à manifestation en en proposant
le samedi d'essayer de durcir mais sans
perdre complètement l'opinion en fait on
voit bien qu'on est dans une stratégie
cohérente finalement de continuer à
séduire et donc je pense que c'est
notamment vraiment ça le premier mot
d'ordre la question de savoir si ça suit
bien ou mal
entre ce qu'on entend
et ce qu'on voit dans la rue quoi c'est
à dire que on a eu par exemple je trouve
dans cette semaine en particulier des
clichés particulièrement triste je
trouve pour notre démocratie où on voit
un article 7 qui passe dans la nuit dans
la deuxième de nos assemblées
parlementaires pas la moindre la plus
conservatrice on se rend compte que
finalement bon voilà on arrive à obtenir
un débat sur la question et un vote et
le même jour on est avec une France à
l'arrêt donc avec beaucoup de gens qui
qui finalement sont hostiles cette
réforme vont la vivre comme un sacrifice
et donc il y a nécessairement un hiatus
qui est en train de se créer et de
s'élargir sans arrêt entre la
représentation nationale qui finalement
suit le jeu normal il faut le dire le
jeu normal d'une discussion
parlementaire là où finalement il y a
plus aucun suivi par les personnes qui
vont recevoir cette réforme donc c'est
vrai qu'on est dans un moment où la
démocratie souffre un peu forcément de
ce décalage et où il faudra penser à la
prêt quels seront les solutions pour
arriver à renouer le dialogue si ce
texte est retiré est-ce qu'il y a encore
une légitimité pour ce gouvernement qui
en a fait un mot d'ordre si ce texte
n'est pas retiré est-ce que il y aura
encore une connexion populaire avec les
élus qui pourtant peuvent tout à fait se
justifier de la légitimité démocratique
il y a vraiment une crise qui est en
train de se jouer Bruno coquet même
question que je formule un peu
différemment est-ce que vous voyez le
mouvement grandit ou c'est rodé
je peux pas faire de prévision non il y
a un point c'est le slogan il y a
quelques semaines le slogan qui est
celui de la réforme aujourd'hui sauver
le régime répartition qui serait une
espèce de Titanic là
c'est ce que disait Gérard Larcher il y
a quelques minutes sur ce plateau donc
un point déjà le système pas répartition
là c'est une réforme paramétrique qui
serait censée le sauver moi je pense que
par rapport à la mobilisation sociale le
système par répartition c'est avant toi
une constat social entre des générations
et puis entre des catégories de
personnes évidemment donc on parle de
contrat social d'un côté et puis de
l'autre côté on parle d'une réforme
balsement paramétrique enfin assez peu
imaginatif avec quelques petits
dispositions sucrées ici ou là bon en
fait on est sur quelque chose de d'assez
bizarre on parle du fond et en même
temps on discute de quelque chose
est triste dont on voit pas très bien où
il nous mène puisque tout le monde dit
d'ailleurs tout le monde est d'accord
pour commencer avant 2030 et puis après
il y a le contexte pour répondre à vos
questions je pense que c'est un autre
point important en plus du contrat
social c'est finalement cette réforme et
l'intervient dans un contexte qui était
assez inattendu
d'inflation extrêmement forte de
revendications salariale de rapport au
travail enfin on voit bien il y a tout
un tas de sujets qui arrivent et
finalement dont on qui vont peut-être
être traités par une loi travail et
finalement dont on aurait aimé qu'il
soit inverser le calendrier de manière à
ce que la retraite nous résolve pas tous
ces problèmes qui existent plus ou moins
dans le monde du travail et qui
finalement on essaye d'expliquer qu'on
va par la retraite et en fait on va rien
résoudre de tout donc du coup pour
répondre à votre question que va-t-il se
passer je fais pas une prévision de
chiffres dans la rue mais il y a ce
contrat social donc c'est un problème de
monde parallèle comme vous l'avez dit
justement avec le Parlement qui fait son
travail qui discute d'une mais de
l'autre côté des un mouvement dans la
rue et il y a pas de contact entre les
deux les leaders des syndicats ont bien
dit on n'a pas eu de téléphone et puis
de l'autre ce contexte économique et
social qui va durer on en a pas fini
avec l'inflation on n'a pas fini avec
les salaires et avec des revendications
diverses et variées la France est-elle à
l'arrêt qui on va je vais vous proposer
de répondre à cette à cette question
dans un instant pas vraiment reconnaît
le secrétaire général de la CGT Philippe
Martinez c'était ce matin sur France 2
c'était une formule en tout cas la
France elle est largement ralentie
et ça va continuer et je vous l'ai dit
ça ne peut que s'amplifier si on
continue à avoir autant d'indifférence
et autant de mépris du côté du pouvoir
alors on reparlera de
la demande qui avait été faite d'être
reçue par le prénom de la République et
la fin de nos recevoir évidemment parce
que ça me semble également un élément
important dans ce hiatus dont vous dont
vous nous parliez mais quand même c'est
Fanny à quel point la France à l'arrêt
c'est c'était entre guillemets la
promesse même si Philippe c'était une
formule mais à quel point le télétravail
est finalement aussi l'inflation dont on
parlait sont des je vais je vais être
volontairement provocateur des briseurs
de grève c'est-à-dire à quel point ça
rend un mouvement social comme celui-là
finalement compliqué à imposer dans dans
un pays comme la France on voit bien en
Île-de-France à peu près il y a 40% des
emplois qui peuvent être télétravaillés
donc véritablement si auparavant il
suffisait de stopper les transports pour
des structuré une activité économique et
bien maintenant depuis le développement
du télétravail depuis la crise covid et
bien il y a il y a de il y a des
solutions les entreprises
en tout cas dans les dans les
départements et généralisé parce que
effectivement on se rappelle pour
certains pour les plus âgés de 95 allez
se rendre au travail c'était quand même
une sinécure donc là on est plus dans
cette situation où
globalement collectivement on doit faire
face à une à un pays un pays à l'arrêt
et on le voit bien de toute manière il y
a pas de les entreprises sont inquiète
sur la durée de de ce mouvement il
faudrait vraiment que ça dure trop
longtemps mais n'empêche que pour
l'instant il y a pas c'est pas leur
c'est pas devenu une problématique ils
sont effectivement plus alarmés sur la
situation de l'inflation que cette ce
blocage lié à la réforme des retraites
Bruno Co les entreprises pourraient
moins souffrir des conséquences de de
cette greffe grâce ou à cause du
télétravail c'est un constat de réalité
et puisqu'on se pose la question autour
de cette table de la la longévité du
mouvement social c'est un élément de
l'équation important est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec ça bien sûr après il
y a la perception alors je vous dis j'ai
un chiffre en tête de mémoire mais les
grèves de 1995 c'est 0,2 point de pipe
sur un trimestre donc on va se dire que
c'était un arrêt gigantesque mais que le
résultat est pas effrayant et donc du
coup effectivement là on est dans un
contexte un petit peu différent le
télétravail pour un certain nombre de
professions résoudre le problème et puis
peut-être aussi que les gens sont un peu
organisés depuis les gilets jaunes la
crise sanitaire enfin c'est un peu le
bazar tout le temps donc je pense que il
y a quand même des gens qui ont des
solutions de secours on voit bien que
les commerces continuent quand même de
tourner plutôt bien enfin pour le moment
donc ça veut dire que le discours mettre
la France à l'arrêt ou mettre l'économie
française à genoux on a aussi entendu ça
de la part de de leaders CGT il est quoi
il est dépassé
le risque c'est un blocage des centres
d'activités c'est-à-dire blocage des
raffineries blocages dans les transports
c'était le risque de pas pouvoir
achalander les la distribution par
exemple donc là il y a un pouvoir que de
nuisance qui existe mais pour l'instant
il est pas mis il est pas mis en
application il serait peut-être aussi
mal perçu et pour revenir sur 95
effectivement pendant un trimestre il y
avait une baisse de 0,2 % du pipe qui a
été totalement rattrapé le trimestre
d'après donc il y a pas d'inquiétude les
entreprises ça elles sont presque
habituées en fait à ces assez phénomène
de grève avec ce phénomène hyper
puissant qui était en 1995 et qui
finalement n'a pas laissé trop de traces
dans l'activité économique aujourd'hui
la France elle reste des camions sur les
ronds-points on voit bien que c'est ça
ça on a on a vécu une grève comme ça
dans le dans le passé on voit bien que
ça c'est un point plus critique surtout
avec ce qui est devenu la logistique
aujourd'hui
Maxime qui joue il y a l'inflation aussi
on a on a parlé autour de cette table je
voudrais vous entendre les caisses de
grève ça marche comment et ça permet de
tenir combien de temps ou alors c'est
une compilation compliquée puisque en
fait il y a une gestion qui est
extrêmement décentralisée il y a
plusieurs cases de grève en fonction des
fédérations en fonction des
établissements
mon sentiment c'est que c'est avant tout
une mesure symbolique qui va pouvoir
permettre dans certains cas de pouvoir
un peu alimenter
certains secteurs qui seront le plus à
l'avant en fait et ça comble pas
forcément le manque à gagner de d'une
journée
calculs qui ont été
approximativement réalisé qui montre que
ça peut couvrir 10 euros par jour par
salarié et pas l'intégrer l'intégrité
des dégrésistes donc on est très très
loin de pouvoir couvrir l'ensemble en
fait du coup de la grève pour les
salariés ça veut dire que c'est
uniquement pardon j'espère je je cherche
pas à vous coller mais que ce sont les
les grévistes syndiqués qui vont pouvoir
en bénéficier c'est pas nécessaire
moi je posais de temps en temps
pour la pédagogie effectivement non non
ce sont l'ensemble des grévistes
pas beaucoup
d'intérêts et de sens non plusina est-ce
que le gouvernement compte sur le
phénomène dont on est en train de parler
dans sa stratégie c'est à dire oui bah
finalement on est dans dans une époque
où le télétravail c'est généralisé et
c'est sans doute structurel il y a de
l'inflation espérons que ce n'est que
conjoncturel est-ce que dans la
stratégie gouvernementale pour faire
passer cette réforme il y a ça depuis le
début je fais un petit come-back avant
de vous répondre d'abord sur la question
de la France à l'arrêt et surtout de
l'économie à genoux je pense vraiment
que c'est ce dogme là qui est le plus
affaibli des deux c'est vraiment cette
idée de ne pas produire de richesses
d'essayer de bloquer un petit peu la
l'avancée de l'économie dans une période
où justement les français craignent pour
leur pouvoir d'achat qui était une
revendication qui là pour le coup aura
quand même beaucoup moins de réalité
avec ce qu'on a dit du télétravail parce
que justement depuis le covid les moyens
de productivité sont quand même bien
développés donc je pense que là c'est
tout à l'heure c'est un peu dépassé
celle-ci va reposer sur un facteur qui
est très intéressant qui est celui de
l'adhésion c'est-à-dire qu'il faut
vraiment avoir des personnes motivées
pour ne pas télétravailler pour ne pas
finalement produire avec des moyens
facilités et donc du coup là on
renouvelle la question de l'adhésion au
mouvement et de la volonté de blocage
donc là là c'est quelque chose de
différent et justement ça répond à votre
question le gouvernement compte
évidemment là-dessus parce que moins
vous avez de gens qui sont enclins à
manifester une volonté de bloquer
c'est-à-dire même avec des moyens
facilités du télétravail etc essayez de
montrer un soutien à la grève et donc de
se mettre finalement en situation de
conflit de travail et de contestation
sociale oui ça va un peu avec la
stratégie d'Emmanuel Macron gilets
jaunes finalement c'est de se dire la
contestation sociale va s'épuiser et
c'est notamment en commençant avec un
discours comme celui de Gabriel Attal
qui nous a dit c'est finalement la
France qui se lève tôt que vous allez
défavoriser puisque l'école blanc
pourronter les travailler donc ça
commence à diviser les Français ça
commence à essayer de marginaliser le
mouvement et évidemment cette stratégie
là et celle du personnellement c'est de
se dire je capitalise sur l'idée que les
Français vont finir par ne plus adhérer
à la popularité de ce gros mots je peux
juste ajouter un élément la parole est
le plus libre possible autour de cet âge
j'espère bien je reviendrai juste une
chose c'est qu'on se focalise beaucoup
sur le télétravail effectivement c'est
une dimension mais les dimensions
sociologique derrière le télétravail et
c'est à dire que les collectifs sont
beaucoup plus atomisées on sait que
autrefois c'était les sagessemblées
générales qui étaient un facteur de
mobilisation après c'est intéressant
donc c'est plus difficile de mobiliser
aussi forcément et chez soi on va voir
il y a des des logiques d'entraînement
en fait dans les mobilisations dans les
assemblées générales leur envol dans une
interview sur contretemps l'explique le
leader de la Fédération des cheminots
explique qu'ils ont beaucoup plus de mal
de à mobiliser désormais en raison en
fait non seulement des de l'éclatement
lié aux réseaux sociaux mais aussi du
télétravail il y a un autre point aimer
les réseaux sociaux pardon ils ont aussi
permis la mobilisation par exemple des
gilets jaunes donc disons a été un outil
de mobilisation aussi j'ai l'impression
que on est à la charnière de nouvelles
formes de mobilisation c'est à dire que
les syndicalistes sont peut-être
à la fin d'un cycle en termes de
répertoire d'action collective et qu'ils
ont besoin finalement qui sont en train
peut-être de s'adapter à des nouvelles
formes de de liens sociaux en fait et de
lien sociaux dans le dans le monde du
travail et que progressivement il va
falloir s'adapter mais l'autre point sur
lequel je voudrais assister aussi sur
des dimensions biologiques de
pour moi c'est pas vraiment un échec
d'arrêt de cette journée à l'arrière
j'ai pas exactement dit ça j'ai
ce qu'on essaie de comprendre c'est
finalement si un mouvement social peut
être aussi efficace qu'avant c'est ça
on peut s'interroger en tout cas c'est
le sens de votre question c'est comme ça
que j'interprète il y a une autre
dimension par rapport à 95 et en 95 il y
avait le salariat était complètement pas
complètement différent mais en grande
partie différente c'est à dire que
c'était beaucoup de fonctionnaires
depuis il y a beaucoup plus de
contractuels avec un rapport beaucoup
plus à l'entreprise et à et au collectif
ce qui fait que aujourd'hui les salariés
ont peut-être un peu moins cette culture
de la mobilisation en tout cas cette
culture d'amélisation est en train de se
transformer et dernier point sur lequel
je finirai c'est que il y a quand même
un point important dans cette réforme
c'est à dire qu'elle vise les futurs
embauchés et ça ça peut avoir ça peut
constituer un frein et à l'élan et à la
durée de la solidarité forcément quand
on est directement concerné comme ça
s'était passé en 2019 et bah forcément
se mobilise plus puisqu'on a envie de
conserver ses droits qu'on a
légitimement à qui au moment de signer
son contrat ou de passer son concours
par exemple dans la fonction publique
quand ça concerne des futurs embauchés
qu'on ne connaît pas selon des modalités
donc là je je lève peut-être un tabou
mais je pense que c'est aussi un facteur
qui peut démobiliser en partie à un
moment on en reparlera tout à l'heure
des régimes spéciaux parce que c'était
l'une des questions qui était évoquée
aujourd'hui au Sénat on attendait un
environnement de Bruno Retailleau
finalement si j'ai bien compris il va
être décalé dans le temps on continue de
parler de la stratégie de
l'intersyndicale et de la responsabilité
du blocage évidemment pour l'Inter
syndical c'est le gouvernement qui porte
ses responsabilités tiens écoutez cette
réaction du secrétaire général de Force
Ouvrière en Ille-et-Vilaine il
manifestait mardi à Rennes on est dans
un bras de fer et effectivement il faut
mettre toutes nos forces on a manifesté
cinq fois ils n'ont rien entendu il y a
eu des mobilisations phénoménales aux
quatre coins de la France aux quatre
coins du département inattendent rien
ces gens-là d'entendre que le rapport de
force donc il est temps de passer dans
le dur maintenant et on est pas maître
du calendrier parlementaire on a 15
jours pour gagner au maximum donc c'est
la grève la grève reconductible et le
blocage il y a pas d'autres solutions et
c'est Macron lui-même qui nous a emmené
dans ce sur cette voie là
l'intersyndicale qui a demandé à être su
par Emmanuel Macron la première ministre
a répondu pour lui en voyant les leaders
syndicaux de vers le ministre du Travail
Olivier du soft brun depuis le début le
décor il est posé il semble assez
immuable en tout cas du côté
gouvernement c'est 64 ans
43 annuités c'est pas négociable donc
pourquoi Emmanuel Macron ouvrirait sa
porte il a rien à négocier vous voyez ce
que je veux dire
oui enfin le point c'est que pour tirer
le fil de ce qui s'est dit avant quand
même c'est que s'il y a des nouvelles
manières de revendiquer de protester il
y a aussi peut-être des nouvelles
manières d'écouter intéressant première
chose la deuxième chose qui me semble
assez inédite c'est que c'est cette
absence de contact c'est pas l'absence
de concession ou le trop plein de
concessions mais l'absence de contact y
compris par des conseillers
Philippe Martinez comme Laurent Berger
l'ont dit tous les deux là il y a
quelques jours alors qu'on sait dans des
mouvements précédents il y avait
évidemment des conseillers un conseiller
social à l'Elysée qui joue un rôle
important monsieur souby voilà qui a
joué qui pouvait être appelé par le
leader de la CGT pour dire bon allez on
va peut-être signer la fin du la fin du
mouvement faites-nous une concession
quoi ça se joue aussi comme ça on le
sait quoi qui sont qui sont appelés tout
le temps et tout ça se place aussi dans
une dans une séquence qui est un peu
curieuse c'est-à-dire on dit le
président de la République promis
pendant sa campagne bon c'était quand
même assez évasif par rapport à ce qu'on
a oui c'était 65 ans c'était clair c'est
peut-être la seule réforme que je suis
censé en retenue d'ailleurs parlait pas
du nombre de trimestres enfin il y avait
un certain nombre enfin c'était alors
c'est pas être précis mais c'était pas
clair après on n'a pas été dans une
négociation ça c'est à dire
le l'étude d'impact de la loi elle
arrive au mois de février le dossier de
presse en grande partie faux d'ailleurs
du 10 janvier
tout ça n'a pas été mis sur la table des
concertations puisque c'était pas des
négociations et finalement on a plutôt
l'impression que c'était quand même des
réunions autour du thé quoi si on se
demande de quoi les gens ont bien pu
discuter si l'étude d'impact est paru
deux mois plus tard et donc du coup on a
cette chose bizarre on a l'impression
quand même que rien n'a jamais été
discuté alors que il pourrait y avoir
d'habitude il y a toujours des ballons
décès dans la presse il y a des choses
on discute deux choses un peu concrètes
on est d'accord pas d'accord et on
s'engage sur une voie là non parce que
on pas l'impression que ça s'est passé
comme ça et donc du coup il est quand
même assez surprenant que de voir
l'absence de contact et l'absence de de
d'audience pour cette revendication un
peu particulière du moment d'accord il y
a un manque de relais alors c'est
peut-être une volonté politique hein de
la part du gouvernement ou de l'Élysée
dans
avec le leaders syndicaux évidemment
alors je vous rejoins aussi lorsque vous
disiez voilà il y a pas de concession
tellement possible à partir du moment où
en fait dès le départ on avait un
président et un gouvernement qui nous
disait voilà nous ça sera 64 et puis
l'allongement des durées hypnotisations
et intercer syndicale qui nous disait
bah nous ça sera tout sauf l'un et
l'autre mais première concessions elles
ont été faites au LR très vite en plus
je rejoins quand même sur l'absence
totale de voilà de de contact de ne
serait-ce que on nous a parlé de faire
de la pédagogie bon peut-être que les
premières personnes avec lesquelles il
fallait en faire c'était les les leaders
syndicaux et peut-être essayer même ne
serait-ce que de montrer un petit peu
que la porte était ouverte et je rejoins
aussi sur un autre point c'est l'effet
de teasing du 10 janvier qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez apporter de constructifs au
dialogue puisque du coup on s'est
retrouvé déjà avec un temps
parlementaire tellement contraint que
comme vous le disiez les concessions en
LR ont été obligés de se faire je crois
la veille du démarrage de la discussion
à l'Assemblée nationale dans un
entretien parisien et on se dit c'est
bien dommage quand même dans une réforme
de 7 ampleur je rappelle que quand même
dans les pays scandinaves parfois on met
deux ans à voter une réforme des
retraites pour arriver à mettre tout le
monde d'accord mais au moins on a ce
consensus on n'a pas cette image non
plus d'une France bloquée qui est
incapable de se réformer parce que je
pense qu'il faut quand même au moins
avoir des voies de discussion Stéphanie
là je vous rappelle qu'au départ avec
cette réforme c'était ce qui était
annoncé par le gouvernement il devait y
avoir un excédent de 19 ou 18 milliards
de d'euros et puis finalement il y a eu
quand même des concessions puisque on
arrive à de nouveau un petit déficit de
600 millions avec les
ajustements qui ont été proposés donc je
veux pas du tout être porte-parole de
qui que ce soit mais quoi il y a eu
quand même des aménagements qui ont été
faits il y a pas il y a pas
a été fait plus en direction de
DLR en prévision de ce débat au Sénat en
ce moment que de l'intersyndical d'une
certaine façon
syndicat effectivement ça c'est une ça
c'est pas discutable je pense que pour
Emmanuel Macron il y a véritablement
cette réforme gravée dans le marbre à
adresser à l'ensemble de des pays de nos
par pays partenaires c'est oui on est
capable de se réformer oui c'était dans
mon mandat je vais pouvoir réformer les
retraites et décaler l'âge de départ à
la retraite je pense que de toute
manière ça c'est quelque chose qui lui
semble incontournable vis-à-vis moi je
pense vis-à-vis de Bruxelles et
vis-à-vis de des marchés financiers et
il peut il peut faire des petits
ajustements à droite à gauche c'est pas
grave en fait si un déséquilibre du
système Infiné en 2030 ce qu'il veut
c'est une communication vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur à dire la France est capable
de se réformer et après ça devient
encore des équations comptables de toute
manière c'est que des équations
comptables depuis le départ il y a pas
véritablement de réforme des retraites
on est quand même dans le rafistolage du
système pour essayer de le rendre à
l'équilibre alors les débats continuent
en ce moment même dans l'hémicycle et on
va régulièrement y rejoindre Alexandre
Poussard qui est en direct de la tribune
de presse Alexandre on va parler de un
peu de stratégie politique avec je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure un abonnement
sur les régimes spéciaux qui finalement
été repoussé bref les sénateurs LR
continuent de jouer le les maîtres des
horloges effectivement Thomas a les
sénateurs la républicains jouent avec
l'ordre d'examen des amendements de
cette réforme des retraites alors
effectivement ce matin le Sénat devait
débattre de la suppression de certains
régimes spéciaux de retrait est une
suppression qui est prévue par la
réforme du gouvernement on le rappelle
la réforme du gouvernement supprime
certains régimes spéciaux de retraite
notamment pour la RATP les transports
les industries électriques et gazières
mais seulement pour les nouveaux
salariés qui vont entrer dans les
entreprises concernées à partir de 2023
c'est ce qu'on appelle la clause du
grand-père et le patron de la droite
sénatoriale Bruno Retailleau veut faire
sauter cette clause du grand-père et que
cette suppression des régimes spéciaux
elle concerne également certains
salariés actuels des entreprises
concernées donc c'est cet amendement qui
devait être débattu ce matin mais c'est
amendement il fait polémique le
gouvernement y est fortement défavorable
car il estime que cela va mettre de
l'huile sur le feu de la mobilisation
sociale donc surtout il ne faut pas
voter cet amendement écoute théâtre ce
matin et bien la droite sénatoriale a
décidé de reporter l'examen de cette
amendement sur la suppression des
régimes spéciaux à plus tard dans ce
texte de la réforme des retraites alors
ça a mis en colère la gauche sénatoriale
qui était prête à débattre des régimes
spéciaux mais la droite a esquiver le
débat écoutez la réponse de Patrick
Kanner le patron des sénateurs
socialistes
alors que Monsieur Retailleau hier nous
a fait une très grande diatribe en
disant vous les obstructeurs je résume
et bien vous utilisez vous utilisez les
arguties pour ne pas
à ce matin je tiens à le dire nous
étions prêts nous étions prêts à
ferrailler monsieur le Président du
Groupe LR et aujourd'hui vous décalez
votre intervention je trouve cela
vraiment extrêmement déloyale à l'égard
du bon déroulement de nos travaux et la
sincérité de nos débats est toujours
très importante y compris par rapport à
d'éventuelles recours devant le Conseil
constitutionnel donc nous sommes prêts
je vous rassure même après l'article 13
nous faire haïrons contre cette Amanda
amendement qui est totalement inique
injuste notamment pour les travailleurs
de ces entreprises qui vont être
supprimées en termes de retraite Merci à
VOUS Alexandre bon on le voit les
tensions sont montées d'un cran
aujourd'hui entre entre la droite et la
gauche effectivement Thomas on le voit
depuis quelques jours il y a des moments
de tension sur ces débats avec la droite
du Sénat qui joue avec le règlement pour
accélérer les débats la gauche qui joue
avec des dizaines des centaines
d'amendements pour justement ralentir
les débats il y a des tensions mais ça
reste plutôt cordiales mais en revanche
cet après-midi et bien on a franchi un
cap dans la tension des échanges entre
les deux côtés de l'hémicycle il y a eu
une véritable altercation entre la
présidente de séances la sénatrice les
républicains Pascal grenier et sénateur
socialiste Ian chanterelle regardez
cette séquence c'est pas la présidente
qui parle c'est la présidence de la
droite on dirait mais bon
[Musique]
on voit en tout cas
vous pouvez demander une suspension de
séance
je reprends la parole monsieur
chanterelle
monsieur chambre trail s'il vous plaît
je reprends la parole jamais vous
pourrez dire ça jamais tant mieux ici
pour tout le monde merci alors
maintenant je vous demande de faire
votre intervention
d'essayer de garder le calme
alors
votre intimidation ne marchera pas merci
je sais que vous essayez je sais que
vous essayez de nous bâillonner de nous
intimider de plus plusieurs depuis hier
dans la totalité du règlement monsieur
Chantrel il y a un article 95 qui dit
très clairement que toute provocation
toute atteinte à la présidence de séance
entraîne la censure voir l'exclusion du
Sénat
et voilà la droite sénatoriale qui
menace d'expulsion un sénateur de gauche
ça arrive très rarement ici à la Haute
Assemblée on le voit que les débats sont
de moins en moins feutrés et d'ailleurs
la droite sénatoriale comme le
gouvernement a dénoncé cet après-midi je
cite la mélenchonisation de la gauche
sénatoriale et ça n'a pas plu au
sénateur socialiste merci alexandre
Poussin on vous retrouve évidemment un
peu plus tard dans dans ce débat Charles
bézina c'est est-ce que le le côté un
peu électrique finalement de l'époque
finit par par déteindre même au Sénat
mais exactement et c'est vrai que on
entend les échanges un peu voilà
énergie on se rend compte que la culture
du Sénat qui est plutôt celle du
compromis du temps finalement est ici
complètement changé mais il faut
rappeler quand même que l'origine c'est
l'artica 47 ans c'est le véhicule
législatif du projet de loi de
financement rectificatif qui laisse
tellement peu de temps
on a une stratégie du Sénat qui consiste
à dire on souhaite proposer un vote
global parce qu'il faut le savoir de
toute façon tant qu'on n'arrive pas à
voter l'intégralité du texte votez un ou
deux ou trois articles ne servira
absolument à rien donc le Sénat à cet
objectif final de dire on veut proposer
au moins un vote d'au moins d'une de nos
deux assemblées sur ce texte si cet
objectif doit arriver à son terme
malheureusement on peut pas le faire
dans le contexte d'une discussion serait
né apaisée parce que il faut
nécessairement maîtriser la montre et
dans ce contre-la-montre finalement on
voit bien que les sénateurs ne sont pas
habitués à ce genre de pratique un petit
peu directive de la part du président de
séance on a on a fait un appel que que
je trouve toujours bienvenu au principe
de clarté du départ parlementaire et à
la saisine du Conseil constitutionnel où
je suis très heureuse que cette
jurisprudence pénètre le Cénac des
assemblées mais encore une fois voilà le
véhicule législatif lui-même fait que on
ne peut pas avoir la sérénité habituelle
de nos débats alors sur les régimes
spéciaux je veux bien ouvrir un chapitre
de ce débat Stéphanie est-ce que vous
dites tout à l'heure cette réforme elle
est défendable elle était mal défendue
est-ce que les régimes spéciaux ça vous
semble logique de les supprimer avec la
clause du grand-père ou alors en allant
plus vite comme le propose enfin où va
le proposer on verra bien le sénateur
Bruno à taille alors je vais parler en
comptable et en économiste oui il faut
les supprimer c'est ce qui coûte cher
c'est l'épine dans dans notre système
c'est ce qui fait que notre système est
largement déficitaire il faut rappeler
quand même que il y a il y a des caisses
de retraite notamment du privé ce qu'on
appelle Argi agir que Arrco et bien qui
sont déjà qui ne peuvent pas être
déficitaires et qui sont même plus
qu'excédentaire parce qu'ils ont une
réserve de plus de 60 milliards donc il
y a des il y a des systèmes dans notre
système qui ont eu une gestion
extrêmement rigoureuse d'autres en fait
qui
les régimes spéciaux c'était des départs
à la retraite très tôt avec une
population d'actifs qui diminuait de
plus en plus c'est à dire qu'on avait de
moins en moins de cheminots et par
contre on avait financé des casino à la
retraite qui était qui était en nombre
et qui partait très jeune je caricature
il y a pas que les cheminots mais en
fait ça comme ça on peut comprendre
rapidement donc et c'est système là qui
véritablement déséquilibre sur le long
terme notre notre système par
répartition donc vous dites c'est
économiquement en tout cas logique de
les supprimer
dans une vraie réforme on parle de
sauver le système donc sauver le système
ça veut dire quand même que tout le
monde se sert la ceinture puisqu'il
c'est ça qu'il faut faire et en
particulier on fait converger les règles
alors est-ce qu'on les fait converger
dans 40 ou 70 ans clairement non parce
que l'argument qui a employé Olivier du
socle qu'on pourrait un certain nombre
de gens qui défendent les régimes
spéciaux j'entends j'incule là-dedans la
fonction publique au sens large enfin
les fonctions publiques au sens large
c'est on va pas réviser le contrat de
travail ces gens là mais dans le privé
c'est ce qu'on fait
tous les gens qui travaillent dans le
privé on révise leur contrats de travail
maintenant et donc du coup l'argument
cet argument là ne tient pas donc il
pourrait le faire mais dans le cadre
d'une vraie réflexion et d'un effort
partagé c'est ce que vous nous c'est ce
que vous nous dites c'est ça parce que
qu'est-ce qui est acceptable dans les
régimes spéciaux c'est la pénibilité
fondamentalement ce que les gens
comprennent c'est que des régimes
spéciaux se justifient pour des métiers
pénibles on peut mourir tôt il y a on
peut pas travailler longtemps etc en
revanche quand à la RATP ou dans les
régimes de bus des villes de province on
n'a pas les mêmes conditions de départ
en retraite c'est un problème un
comptable de la SNCF il n'est pas plus
épuisé que un comptable d'une entreprise
privée et donc du coup ça ça peut se
discuter c'est à dire un trade d'Off il
y a une demande sur la pénibilité y
compris dans le secteur privé donc on
traite la pénibilité tout secteurs
confondus ont fait con les règles et de
l'autre côté et bien du coup on fait
aussi converger les règles en faisant en
sorte que il n'y ait pas de situation un
peu privilégiée et héritage du passé
dans certains régimes puissent encore
une fois il s'agit de sauver le régime
et le contrat social donc c'est jouable
mais il faut discuter avant
Maxime tout à l'heure que la finalement
la suppression de la Claus du grand-père
a supposition des régimes spéciaux pour
ceux qui vont arriver à partir du 1er
septembre c'était un ferment aussi de
division et qu'il pouvait jouer sur la
la longévité du mouvement mais au-delà
de ça est-ce que
ceux qui subsistent sont
anachroniques ou pas c'est à dire RATP
DF etc alors c'est une question
compliquée est-ce qu'ils sont
anachroniques moi je pense qu'il faut
mettre en place des véritables
négociations effectivement je pense que
les gens qui sont les premiers concernés
par ces régimes spéciaux ont beaucoup de
choses à dire probablement beaucoup de
choses à proposer sur leur propre régime
de retraite et qu'il faudrait peut-être
leur ouvrir la porte les accueillir et
avoir une discussion un peu générale
mais je pense que c'est comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure c'est des
questions de société c'est pas ça parce
qu'ils y sont prêts bien sûr les
syndicats la plupart des syndicats la
plupart des fédérations ont toujours des
propositions contrairement à l'image
qu'on veut véhiculer des syndicats les
syndicats ont toujours des propositions
et d'ailleurs il se fatigue même de dire
m'attendais on a un ensemble de choses à
proposer on n'est pas simplement dans la
prochaine station y compris Philippe
Martinez donc je pense que on voit bien
qu'il y a un problème en fait
démocratique et de et de concertation de
consultation de réflexion collective en
fait sur le devenir de ces régimes
spéciaux et de la retraite en général
après je veux juste souligner c'est
qu'on a des problèmes de recrutement
dans toutes les fonctions publiques on a
un gros problème là-dessus alors les
questions de salaire évidemment mais il
y a aussi peut-être c'était aussi un peu
la carotte quand on rentrait dans ces
secteurs ou les carrières étaient quand
même relativement peu attractive c'était
de dire au moins je vais pouvoir partir
relativement tôt dans des conditions
plus ou moins favorables et aujourd'hui
on voit bien que c'est cette carotte
n'attire même plus donc je pense que il
faut pas sous-estimer ce point là parce
que on va vers une catastrophe aussi en
terme de recrutement vous êtes d'accord
c'est au niveau macro là où il y a le
plus de pénurie de main d'oeuvre c'est
dans les secteurs privés avec une
pénibilité alors c'est plutôt le secteur
de l'hôtellerie restauration autant
entendu parler après la crise covid les
gens ne veulent plus travailler en
horaires décalé ou au salaire horaire
auto horaire qu'on leur propose et c'est
la même chose aussi pour les
aides-soignantes qui ne sont pas des
fonctionnaires et qui sont en horaires
décalés et qui doivent travailler du du
lundi au dimanche donc sur les 305 il y
a à peu près 350 000 actuellement postes
vacants en France c'est c'est beaucoup
plus que dans le dans le secteur dans le
secteur public j'entends bien mais moi
je suis très favorable à créer des
régimes spéciaux pour ces gens là aussi
il y a pas de problème
je vous redonne la parole
justement on a parlé depuis tout à
l'heure de ce qui pourrait être
justifiable ou pas dans cette
suppression des régimes spéciaux et on
tourne en fait autour de l'argument clé
qui est vraiment historiquement celui
des Français c'est l'injustice sociale
en fait et c'est vrai que je pense qu'on
est tard dans ce débat pour poser cette
question de la suppression des régimes
spéciaux mais finalement on retourne un
peu sur le problème de pédagogie si on
avait peut-être parlé de ça plutôt et
notamment justifier ça par des
conditions d'égalité ou par comme vous
le disiez économiquement l'idée que
c'est ça qui pose des problèmes
peut-être que des choses auraient été
vraiment possible à partir du moment où
vous tablez sur cette question de la
justice et de l'égalité pour lesquelles
les Français sont prêts à se battre et
voilà si on avait abordé cela avant
peut-être qu'on aurait pu trouver des
voies dialogues un petit peu plus clair
oui intervenir c'est vrai c'est juste
dans la fonction publique typiquement il
y a des problèmes de recrutement on le
sait dans l'enseignement on sait que
dans les métiers de la santé il y a des
problèmes de recrutement il y a des
problèmes de salaire mais pourquoi le
point est un blocage qui n'est pas
discuté maintenant c'est parce qu'on
essaye de résoudre au travers de la
retraite des problèmes qui se durant
l'emploi c'est à dire que les salaires
sont insuffisants dans les métiers que
je viens de citer et dans certains
autres en particulier les métiers de la
sécurité enfin les métiers régaliens et
donc du coup on voit bien que ce n'est
pas possible et que ça crée forcément
des points de blocage quoi et donc du
coup faut discuter avant tout simplement
allez-y tous les régimes spatiaux ne
sont pas visés aussi je veux dire alors
là ça rejoint le point que vous étiez en
train de souligner c'est-à-dire que
alors ça on en parle pas beaucoup mais
il y a plein de régimes spéciaux quand
même qui ne sont pas visés y compris
celui des sénateurs par exemple je pense
que c'est pas le plus cool
mais c'est pas que des questions
économiques c'est des questions
symboliques et vous avez raison
d'insister là
ce serait pas forcément été possible
pour les sénateurs les députés les
ministres et le président de la
République puisque c'est dans des lois
organiques et bon voilà
il y a d'autres régimes il y a la police
il y a la Comédie Française donc ça
donne un peu une image un peu
incompréhensible c'est-à-dire que
j'entends souvent mais ce que je
reprends c'est le
peut-être l'absence de en tout cas de
compréhension d'un effort collectif avec
cette réforme c'est ce que vous voulez
de par exemple les retraités actuels
eux-mêmes sont pas mis à contribution il
pourrait l'être oui c'est vrai les
retraités pourraient être mis à
contribution alors c'est c'est pas la
tradition la difficulté c'est que
effectivement on dit voilà ça a été une
génération dorée ils ont eu accès à
l'emploi au logement ils ont une belle
retraite ils sont pas payé beaucoup de
cotisations super sauf que si on le fait
maintenant ça va concerner qui
pas massivement ceux qui sont déjà à la
retraite mais massivement ceux qui vont
partir et qui déjà subissent la réforme
donc il faut faire attention à la
dynamique de l'argument autant quand on
regarde le passé on se dit oui c'est un
peu logique il faudrait bien qu'il paye
un jour et mais quand on regarde le
futur y compris le futur proche on se
rend bien compte déjà puisque on sait
bien comme vous le rappeliez tout à
l'heure qui va y avoir un ratio actif
sur retraité qui va diminuer or on m’a
maintient la dépense dans le pub ce que
ça veut dire c'est que les retraites
vont baisser par rapport au niveau de
vie moyen des autres enfin des actifs de
manière générale et donc du coup il faut
faire assez attention à ce que
l'argument qui serait approprié pour les
générations jusque là ne l'est pas
forcément là dans les quelques années
qui viennent Stéphanie Miller c'est
ensuite on retourne dans les lances
effectivement cibler sur les retraités
d'aujourd'hui avec la hausse de la CSG
en 2017
2018 avec Emmanuel Macron ça a été quand
même elle perçue à la fois par les
retraités mais aussi par une grande
partie de l'opinion publique qui était
contre en fait cette cette hausse de la
CSG qui devait permettre aux salariés du
privé de ne plus payer des cotisations à
chômage qui ont été supprimées et il
fallait en fait rebasculer donc tout le
monde a eu cette hausse de la CSG et
notamment les retraités et ça a été très
mal perçu ça c'est même traduit
économiquement parce qu'on a vu un
essoufflement de la consommation à
partir de de l'annonce de cette hausse
de la CSG donc il y a une incidence
économique de ce genre de mesure et
comme premier retour dans l'hémicycle
avec Alexandre Poussard dans la tribune
de presse rebonjour Alexandre avec un
amendement défendu par les sénateurs et
l'air sur les carrières des maires de
famille qui a été adopté cet après-midi
c'est ça effectivement Thomas on
l'entend beaucoup dans ce débat sur la
réforme des retraites les femmes
seraient les perdantes de cette réforme
du gouvernement car elle doivent et bien
travailler un petit peu plus longtemps
que les hommes elles ont des pensions de
retraite qui sont plus basses elles ont
des carrières hachées et donc pour
donner un petit coup de pouce au maire
de famille la droite sénatoriale a
proposé une surcote des pensions de
retraite des maires de famille qui ont
une carrière complète à partir de 63 ans
et si elle travaille jusqu'à 64 ans et
bien elles auront une hausse de leur
pension pouvant aller jusqu'à 5% alors
pour la droite sénatoriale c'est
amendement il a aussi un objectif de
relance de la natalité française écoutez
Bruno retaillon c'est un homme en
fondamental parce que l'impensé de la
réforme du gouvernement c'est la
démographie un régime par répartition
c'est un régime justement de transition
démographique et intergénérationnel les
femmes sont déjà les grandes perdantes
puisque vous l'avez tous souligné les
maires de famille encore plus puisqu'on
écrase les trimestres de majoration avec
les deux années de recul c'est quelque
chose de fondamental on ne peut pas
penser l'avenir notre régime sans une
politique familiale qui soit une
politique familiale vraiment vigoureuse
et volontaire alors du coup cet
après-midi un débat très intéressant
c'est ouvert entre les sénateurs de
gauche et les sénateurs de droite sur la
natalité dans notre pays et pour
certains sénateurs de gauche et bien
faire reposer cet enjeu démographique
sur les femmes les inciter à faire des
enfants c'est une politique rétrograde
écoutez l'écologiste Mélanie Vogel pour
moi la famille n'est pas une valeur la
famille c'est une institution et comme
tous les institutions mais c'est pas un
gros mot institution excusez moi je sais
pas ce que c'est le problème que vous
avez avec le mot institution c'est une
institution comme toutes les
institutions ce sont des constructions
sociales et comme toutes les
constructions sociales elles ont
vocation à évoluer et nous avons le
projet de faire évoluer la famille pour
qu'elle soit moins concentrée sur l'idée
que la fille que la famille est une
affaire de femmes que les femmes sont là
pour faire des enfants et pour s'en
occuper
et voilà donc au terme de ce débat la
majorité de droite et du centre du Sénat
à voter en faveur de cette surcote des
pensions de retraite des maires de
famille avec et bien l'apport de
certaines voies de sénateurs de gauche
qui estiment que cette mesure était
quand même bonne à prendre pour les
maires de famille et noter que cette
surcote est bien elle devrait rester
dans la version finale de la réforme des
retraites car les sénateurs les
républicains en font et bien une ligne
rouge pour soutenir cette réforme des
retraites et puis le gouvernement y est
favorable dernier mot Alexandre le Sénat
également débattu aujourd'hui du
dispositif carrière longue effectivement
le dispositif qui prévoit des départs
anticipés pour ceux qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt alors dans le débat
beaucoup de sénateurs ont estimé que
c'était une véritable
usine à gaz je vais essayer de vous
l'expliquer il y a plusieurs bornes
d'âge pour prévoir ces départs anticipés
les Français qui ont commencé à
travailler avant 16 ans pourront s'ils
ont tout leur trimestre cotisé et bien
partir à 58 ans pour ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler entre 16 et 18 ans
ils pourront partir à 60 ans et pour
ceux qui ont commencé à travailler entre
18 et 20 ans ils pourront partir à 62
ans et noter que cet après-midi le Sénat
a voté une nouvelle borne d'âge dans ce
dispositif carrière longue les Français
qui ont commencé à travailler entre 20
et 21 ans pourront partir à 63 ans
c'était une concession faite par le
gouvernement notamment sous la pression
du député les républicains Aurélien
Pradier et puis une autre mesure qui a
été votée par le Sénat aujourd'hui et
qui concerne ces carrières longues et
bien les Français qui sont nés en 19
entre 1962 et 1963 et qui ont commencé à
travailler tôt ils pourront partir dans
un départ anticipé aux conditions
actuelles et ne sont donc pas concernés
par cette réforme des retraites bravo
franchement Alexandre pour quelqu'un qui
dort aussi peu depuis une semaine
c'était particulièrement clair merci à
vous merci aussi à Quentin calm sur les
directs évidemment à toutes les équipes
de Public Sénat et de la rédaction.fr
qui est sur le pont depuis et qu'il le
sera encore jusqu'à dimanche on peut pas
prendre tous les thèmes moi je vais me
concentrer sur le les carrières des
maires de famille carrière des femmes
Stéphanie est-ce que vous reprenez à
votre compte le fait que les femmes sont
les grandes perdantes de cette de cette
réforme alors moi je pense que elle est
les femmes sont les perdantes pendant la
vie active et ça se répercute en fait
sur sur au moment de la retraite la
réforme des retraites ne pourra pas
changer ce qui ce qui se passe pendant
l'activités
ça ne peut pas rattraper le doigt une
femme à la retraite gagne 40% de moins
que que un homme alors oui maintenant ça
va peut-être être un peu moins grâce à
ces 5% mais on voit bien que ça compense
absolument pas en fait l'écart qui qui
existe entre un retraité homme et
une femme une femme à la retraite
ensuite pour
considérer que une hausse de 5% de de
la retraite va permettre de relancer la
natalité je pense que on se trompe de
débat il faut voir qu'il y a quand même
une évolution dans notre société depuis
les années 70 en fait on le taux de
fécondité des femmes abaissées pourquoi
parce qu'elles sont elles sont
massivement intégrées le marché du
travail aujourd'hui on est à 1,7 enfants
par femme est-ce que réellement on peut
demander aux jeunes filles de est-ce que
c'est dans leurs objectifs d'avoir une
famille nombreuse donc la réalité en
fait
il faut la considérer telle qu'elle est
c'est elle a été le Kelly c'est si on
arrive à avoir à maintenir un taux de
fécondité autour de deux c'est déjà bien
parce que je rappelle quand même qu'on a
un des taux de fécondité les plus élevés
de l'Union européenne malgré sa baisse
reste l'un des plus élevés on est 1,7
sachant qu'en Allemagne c'est 1,4 voire
bientôt 1,2 donc Maxime qui joue
comprenez les
sénatrice de gauche qui ont voté
l'amendement proposé par les LR c'est
quand même un petit progrès écoutez je
sais pas suivi donc je préfère pas
de souci vous avez le droit elle est
suffisamment complexe cette réforme pour
pas forcément tout suivre Dieu du début
à la fin Bruno vous dites que cette
réforme elle est une malédiction aussi
pour cette génération j'ai vu ça dans
une tribune pourquoi parce que à partir
du moment où on a annoncé qu'on
résorbait le déficit en 2030 ça veut
dire qui résorbe le déficit alors après
il se passe des choses parce qu'on
remonté l'âge de la retraite de deux ans
donc mais le avancer le nombre de enfin
avant c'était d'une part rehausser l'âge
pour les générations y compris immédiate
et d'autre part augmenter le nombre de
trimestres qui pour avoir une retraite à
taux plein fait que mécaniquement toutes
les économies réalisées d'ici 2030
portent sur les générations qui partent
à la retraite d'ici 2030 donc ça fait
100 milliards enfin un peu moins autour
de 80 milliards d'euros
les mesures sucrées ne diminuent pas
mais elles augmentent ce coût parce que
c'est pas les mêmes qui vont bénéficier
des mesures sucrées et qui vont perdre
de leurs droits donc du coup on voit
bien que on a une réforme qui pèse
massivement sur les 7 générations du
coup à venir et donc et là-dedans en
particulier comme on le disait sur les
femmes alors avec toujours cette
caractéristique qu'on essaye de résorber
un problème de marché du travail par une
disposition dans les retraites dont on
n'est pas sûr que d'une d'autre part
qu'elle sera durable puisque dans les
jeunes générations les écarts sont
moindres entre hommes et femmes et donc
du coup il y a pas forcément besoin de
comment de dispositions spécifiques et
surtout de disposition incompréhensible
moi je suis pas qui a compris l'histoire
de la surcote sans compter que on a
oublié que les trimestres pour les
enfants il y avait des trimestres de
maternité mais les trimestres
d'éducation qui peuvent se passer entre
les deux donc du coup ça veut dire
est-ce que si la mère passe des
trimestres au père le père va-t-il
pouvoir partir à 63 ans
parce que c'est suffisamment complexe si
je vous interrompre au milieu on va
vraiment pleurer est-ce que c'est pas le
lot de toute réforme des retraites non
non non si on commence à balayer
l'escalier par le haut c'est-à-dire à
poser l'ensemble des problèmes on n'a
pas on en a évoqué quelques-uns les
régimes spéciaux intergénérationnel les
femmes etc on voit bien qu'est-ce qui
est facile qu'est-ce qui peut faire
l'objet de combinaison ou de
d'échanges et où sont les pointures et
là on en est à mettre des pansements des
surpensments des rustines sur un truc
extrêmement faible
faut pas oublier le le l'enjeu politique
en fait c'est à dire que pourquoi la
carrière des femmes et les carrières
longues parce que c'est les deux seuls
points avec les 1200 euros dont on a
beaucoup entendu parler à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc le Sénat passe un
petit peu de pommade on est vraiment
dans le côté sucré et comme on le disait
j'ajoute aussi qu'on a on a parlé de
mettre en uniquement avec le phénomène
de la retraite et je vous rejoins
largement on a par exemple un système
fiscal qui est encore fondé sur l'idée
qu'on ne gagne des parcs à partir du
moment où on a un troisième enfant bon
voilà il y a beaucoup de choses qui font
dans la réalité pratique la justice
sociale elle est elle est affaire de de
de réglage suffisamment fin pour que
cette pédagogie enfin voilà soit amené
bien avant ce débat parlementaire et on
rejoint à nouveau cette idée que les
concessions politiques font
qu'aujourd'hui ce projet n'a plus
franchement la lisibilité qu'il avait au
départ et peut-être aurait-il dû gagner
à être négocié avant sur ces points là
alors je voudrais on recevait pour ceux
qui nous ont rejoint au cours d'émission
le président du Sénat en tout début de
sciences publiques gérarchie on lui a il
a été critiqué de depuis 24 48 heures
sur l'utilisation
d'articles du Règlement du Sénat qui
permet d'accélérer les débats je
simplifie notamment l'article 38 le
position de gauche qui se dit bâillonner
et l'accuse de partialité on écoute la
réponse Gérard Larcher il s'agit en
quelque sorte d'avoir un temps cadré
pour examiner des articles et
ceci était issu d'ailleurs d'un retour
d'expérience de texte parce que il
s'agit pour un président d'assemblée
j'assume cet article puisque c'est Soum
ma présidence que cet article a été mis
en place le rôle du Parlement c'est
vraiment je le répète
de délibérer et de voter
2015 nous a dit Gérard Larcher
c'est un peu le frère jumeau du temps
législatif programmé qui existe à
l'Assemblée nationale le Sénat n'avait
jamais actionné donc c'est une première
c'est quelque chose auquel en plus on a
parlé de la culture du Sénat tout à
l'heure et bien auquel les sénateurs
n'étaient absolument pas rompu néanmoins
ce que nous dit le président ici c'est
que
avec le temps qui lui restait il assume
complètement l'idée de pouvoir
arriver jusqu'à l'objectif alors
j'ajoute que normalement sur les textes
financiers justement l'Assemblée
nationale n'a pas le droit normalement
d'actionner le TLP le temps législatif
programmé pour laisser quand même un
petit peu de temps à la discussion mais
c'est vrai qu'ici voilà on voit bien que
tous les artifices sont les bons pour
essayer d'arriver à l'efficacité à
rationaliser un petit peu les choses et
ça nous ramène la discussion qu'on a eu
on a évoqué le 49-3 l'hypothèse que
finalement c'est le gouvernement doit en
passer par un 49-3 à l'Assemblée et les
conséquences et déterminer là-dessus que
ça pourrait avoir justement sur la
mobilisation et sur l'action des
grévistes vous nous disiez tout à
l'heure Maxime qui joue qui avait quand
même quoi une crainte que le mouvement
finisse par échapper aux leader
syndicaux c'est une possibilité ça alors
c'est une possibilité et c'est une
crainte sur laquelle alerte les
organisations syndicales dans le
communiqué qu'ils ont sorti quand même
je joue juste une petite phrase pour nos
organisations c'est absence de réponse
de la part du chef de l'État constitue
un grave problème démocratique donc ça
c'est un constat mais surtout il conduit
immanquablement une situation qui
pourrait devenir explosive donc ça c'est
le comité inter syndical qui est quand
même assez explicite sur
l'alerte qui lance en disant attention à
un moment donné on pourra peut-être plus
maîtriser nos bases nos bases et le pays
en règle générale faut faire très
attention parce que l'épisode gilet
jaune est pas très loin il pourrait
inspirer des salariés on a vu déjà des
formes de d'hybridation on va dire de
forme de mobilisation sur les ronds etc
on n'est pas à l'abri un jeu alors la
dernière fois je crois qu'il y a
quelqu'un d'un institut de sondage qui
expliquait que je crois que c'était 8
Français sur 10 qui craignaient une
exposition sociale ah non je crois que
c'était lundi dernier dans votre
émission et je pense que on s'entoure
que ça sent un peu le oui mais il y a
aussi on va pas citer tous les instants
mais il y a aussi
une espèce de lassitude de fatalisme je
sais pas quel terme employé qui
s'exprime encore chez une majorité de
Français qui se disent de toute façon la
loi finira par passer vous voyez ce que
je veux dire il y a deux sur deux
sentiments un peu contradictoires en
fait si on essaie de se projeter
absolument c'est-à-dire que c'est la
fatalité la cause du désespoir qui peut
être un levier de mobilisation mais un
levier de mobilisation qu'on pourra pas
contrôler donc il faut vraiment faire
très attention et c'est ce à quoi
appelle finalement le le communiqué de
l'Inter syndicale en disant attention on
l'a vu en plus hein c'est-à-dire qu'il y
a eu des mobilisations l'année dernière
qui ont complètement échappé aux
organisations syndicales alors sur des
bases très corporatives etc mais c'est
un risque
sur lequel alerte à Laurent Berger l'a
alerté encore une fois il y a quelques
jours dans c'est ce soir je crois
c'était fait quand on regarde les
différents sondages on a quand même
l'impression que la principale menace
pour les Français c'est l'inflation et
je suis pas sûr que ils aient envie de
véritablement se mobiliser sur le temps
long pour la réforme des retraites c'est
peut-être aussi pour ça qu'il considère
que elle va un moment elle va passer et
se mobiliser et faire grève bien c'est
un coup et les Français dans une phase
inflationniste se disent bien que ça va
être compliqué de se mettre en situation
d'arrêt c'est terminé malheureusement je
suis désolé à tout petit mot besoin 10
secondes et les mobilisations
effectivement la grève peut-être mais
c'est ça qui va échapper peut-être c'est
comme on sera sur d'autres types de
mobilisation on va pas contrôler on
verra bien merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat encore une
fois et à bientôt sur sur Public Sénat
la rédaction je vous le disais elle
reste mobilisée en direct sur le canal
13 et puis sur public sénat.fr pour vous
faire vivre de l'Intérieur voilà les
séances au plus près ce soir demain
pendant tout le week-end et puis demain
dans la matinale tiens votre prochain
rendez-vous l'invité politique de
rayonnement sinistre ce sera Eric
Coquerel le président insoumis la France
insoumise de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale belle soirée à
toutes et à tous